[Music]  take him off in here right here  [Music]  [Music]  the check please  I just wanna  [Music]  so you come  [Music]  [Music]  Nastasia  I want you back have dinner with me  okay fine I'll have dinner with you  because I'm hungry gotta be quicker than  that Cray are you happy  I've never been happier he's changing  [Music]  this time no rules no punishments and no  more secrets  [Music]  you know that girl Kristian  [Music]  do you think you're the first woman  who's tried to save me  that's how many watts anymore  your boyfriend has a reputation  do you want to be kept  or have respect  if something were to happen to you I  could never forgive myself tell me what  you have that I don't  it's rated R  that dinner with me okay fine I will  have dinner with you  because I'm hungry but we are only  talking and that is